il n'est pas si bon dit il est beaucoup
plus intéressant en confiance la
première chose qui vient qui vous saute
aux yeux
me saute aux yeux - en penser à nathalie
sont précisément ces yeux pense à la
montre est tout simplement pas encore
circonstances d'une boîte de nuit
présenté par des amis communs et ça a
été une rencontre assez violente je peux
dire entre deux étaient très grossier tu
feras coup j'étais assis sur mon sac
c'est tout simplement la nuit et il
était avec des amis à lui qui me
plaisait pas tellement qu'il invoque de
juin et en mati qu'alain delon est large
qui a brui des pauvres en effet selon le
cartel et il était assis sur mon sac
alors je lui dis est ce que ça vous en
dirai pas de vous lever un tout petit
peu pour que je puisse prendre les
effets pas prendre votre sac j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] at-il dit allait dépêcher
vous voyez bien je suis occupée
quel est ton plus grand défaut à kohler
coléreux épouvantable égoïste est très
élevé le défi de ma vie je constance
dans les yeux il ya une expression tout
à fait particulière venant faire mon
avis une virilité surtout dans le corps
c'est amusant pas d'envisager un visage
un peu de l'ain visage plein de
tendresse
je ne peux absolument pas ouvert un
tiroir trouver des armes là il ya une
faible quantité de paix comme sa mère
souvent ville on s'entraîne tous les
voisins fait une pétition parce que
impossible de passer le week-end
tranquillement alors à 9 heures du matin
profitant au mieux les enfants sont
réveillés par des coups de revolver
table en un dieu oui en odieux qui
n'était pas le mien qui était pâle
obtient il croit en quelque chose en
tout cas en une force quelconque
surnaturel il s'intéresse à la politique
oui s'intéresser à la politique et à de
gaulle en particulier un jour à la dure
c'était le courage de rentrer dans cette
cage n'est pas tellement le courage en
fait mais là je les prie pour lui pour
lui montrer que c est lui et gérard dans
cette cage et ce chien qui était
absolument épouvantable terroriser mais
alors les journalistes entre autres
quand il m'a vu rentrer dans cette cage
à limbé son revolver parce qu'ils ne
rentrent dans cette cache qu'avec un
revolver je sais pas cela vraiment je
suis absolument pas que les chinois il
ya des agressions chinoise il a dû
rapporter ces du chef pour ce chien
s'est pris d'une passion subite pour moi
et a commencé à me faire des tas de
tendresse comme embrasser et ce qui a
éveillé alors c'est amusant depuis ce
jour où fut entre dans cette cage entre
lui et alain aînés c'est marrant sont
deux mâles en fête est née une espèce de
d'antipathie tu vas les traits policier
quelque chose la sbee et surtout même
assez à ses amitiés et surtout pas y
toucher
quant à sa femme dans pas longtemps
j'espère à la main tout le temps mais
ils m'ont tu vas pour des petites choses
c'est pas vraiment un moteur dans ce
sens qu'ils n'aiment pas mentir en fait
continue c'est parce qu'il ya aura aussi
expliqué un jour comme ça je marche
auprès d'alain et puis il ya ma gauche
et d'un charme envers son entrepôt dans
une voiture est alors l'invitée de forme
- et donc ne me regarder absolument pas
et puis j'ai regardé ce garçon on pense
on tient il ne vais pas fini de regarder
qu'à la manif étudiante aide avant même
que je regarde il avait déjà pensé que
j'allais mourir
à chaud c'est à cette forme à l'avant du
très très brusquement à la conduite en
ville et où c'est à dire
cette voiture enfin quelle que soit la
voiture il a vendu nerveusement
conduit un peu
murray j'imagine
à lundi scorpions et voit un scorpion
c'est quelqu'un qui détruit tout et
inconsciemment il le fait d'ailleurs je
crois pas tellement aussi mais alors là
c'est frappant parce que si tu veux un
scorpion quand on imagine un scorpion
d'après ce qu'on a pu me dire ça parce
que j'ai pu voir un scorpion pic
on sentait que l'autodestruction une
mère après il le sait mais ça n'a aucune
importance n'existe pas contre un
million - scorpions c'est le bras de fer
contre le pot de fer
ça fait des étincelles mais c'est la
plus passionnante de poule contre pot de
fer contre le pot de fer
oui c'est un peu vrai mais alors c'est
grave parce qu'il n'ya pas de solution
parce que pot de fer ne cache jamais
rempli de bosses ne se casse pas alors
ça peut durer entre un et sa mère il ya
une grande ressemblance physique d'abord
qui est étonnante
moralement ils ont deux points communs
mon avis c'est le goût du travail et
goody drame nat
map il s'habille mali s'habille comme il
aime d'ailleurs très bien mais ils
aiment souvent enfin mal mont d'or se
déguisait surtout quand on s'y attend
pas aujourd'hui si on est entre amis à
la maison pendant une soirée enfin très
habillée travail il a disparu cinq
minutes et puis on l'a vu rentrer vêtu
d'une chemise de nuit à montréal qc baby
doll avec une perruque blonde et
bigoudis sur la tête en face était très
très comique et c'est la première fois
d'ailleurs j'ai remarqué des mêmes
ressembler un peu que je ressentais open
beaucoup ça fait blement passait mal
[Musique]